I'm
making the decision to
I think it's an
excess not only because it
allows us to return to
France but of course because Paris
is becoming a high place
for research in AI and machine
learning indeed  we have a multitude
of research laboratories in
universities and engineering schools
public research centers as well as
a large number of certain
dia points which appear and the big
boxes also which settle so it is
a good thing  que marine says
are part of this network and can
collaborate with this scientific community in
order to contribute to
research in its themes and also
contribute to the training of students
at the level of research themes
we will do research in ai in
machine learning andy  planning its
deep neural networks as
well as in reinforcement learning
just a word about
launch learning since it is a q domain  ui
is a little less known on which I
worked
the objective is to allow a
computer to learn by itself from
its own experience a little in the same
way that a child learns to explore
its environment for example the way
which a child learns to ride a bicycle
is not to solve differential equations
of system dynamics
no they try they see what
happens maybe he falls he gets up he
starts again and so he learns little by
little so it's  this type of learning
by trial and error by experience
that we want modeled
in member learning at the moment
so says marine is going to open this lab in
paris this summer
we want to collaborate with the
scientific community
we are going to do basic research
but bearing in mind the
desire that this research be beneficial
to society and create
values ​​in people's lives